(upbeat music)
- Welcome to a new episode
of Worth It One Stop.
It's a new show where
we try foods that are
uniquely worth it in
their own worth it ways.
This is Rie.
- Hi.
- Today we're gonna be trying
out some expensive grapes.
How expensive?
We were gonna buy $1,000
grapes but we found out
somebody actually bought
them in the last 24 hours.
So we can't get 'em anymore.
That's crazy.
- Yeah.
- So it's worth it to somebody.
What would you say are the
main differences between
American grapes and Japanese grapes?
- We don't eat the skin.
- What?
- We peel the skin and
eat the fruit inside.
- Interesting.
- Oh.
You know what else is in
peak season right now?
- What's that?
- Cicadas. Oh my gosh.
Walking through a garden
and they're just like.
(whining noise)
- Yeah, it's their garden.
- Okay. Nature's beautiful.
I'm not gonna be a hater going in.
- You don't have grape expectations?
- Ooh, nice.
- That's actually good one.
(laughter)
- Thank you, Rie.
(upbeat music)
- I think
- Whoa, is that an apple?
- Yeah.
- Oh. Look at the spots.
- This is my favorite thing.
This melon.
The way that the stem is
perfectly straight like that.
- Rie, do you have like a favorite fruit?
- Peach in Japan.
It's like bigger, juicier.
- [Steven] Those look like butts.
- And now here are the grapes.
They're just like really big.
Don't touch.
- Wait I can't touch this?
- No. No touching.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Can you tell us a little bit about
the culture of fruits in Japan?
(speaking in foreign language)
Why are these grapes so expensive?
This is not normal, right?
What makes it so expensive?
(speaking in foreign language)
- Boom.
- That is a present.
It looks like an award, too.
It actually makes a lot of sense.
Getting a gift of fruit for somebody.
If I'm gonna buy, you know, my girlfriend
a gift, and I get her flowers,
they're beautiful but she can't eat them.
- So you're never going to buy
your girlfriend flowers again?
Only fruit?
- If, you know, yeah.
No. That's not true.
Sorry, no.
1,000 grams.
- This is a very nice box.
Can I keep this box?
Oh, yeah.
The key component of giving a good
gift is the package it comes in.
Yeah.
- Sure. It's like a joke.
You can't just deliver the punchline.
- Right.
- You gotta give it setup.
- You can't just throw a grape at someone.
You gotta bring it in a nice box.
- Throw the box at 'em.
- It's a nice wood smell to the box.
- Good feel.
May the unboxing commence.
- You have a little.
- It's like buying an
iPhone with the manual.
- It's like a certificate.
- And here's how you turn it on.
- How do you say grape?
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh my god they're so heavy.
I like this bag.
It's a breathable bag on the bottom.
They're very firm too.
- It's like holding a baby.
- [Woman] Can I hold it too?
- Oh, yes.
- [Woman] Is it heavy?
- It's not the size of a baby.
- [Steven] Small baby.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh my god.
Look at how perfectly
lined up those grapes are.
- These are the grapes in video games
that you jump up and eat and
they give you a new life.
Let's eat.
- [Andrew] Whoa.
- [Woman] Nature is beauty.
- Hold on, I gotta get a picture of this.
Just me and my grapes.
- Can you peel this?
- Sure.
(oohing)
- [Steven] Look at it.
Just take off. Yeah.
- One, two, three, four.
32, 33, 34. 35 grapes.
- So each grape is $57.
(laughter)
- The inside is so special looking.
Oh it's dripping with juice. Adam.
- Segoi.
- Cheers.
- Cheers. 3, 2, 1.
(upbeat music)
- Holy crap.
Like without a doubt, okay.
It is the best grape I've ever had.
- Can I have another $57 grape?
It's crazy. It kind of
tastes like plum flavor.
- That was crazy.
- This one looks especially plump.
Oh yeah.
- 57 more dollars.
It's a little disorienting.
- Inside.
- Putting a grape
this big in your mouth.
- Yeah.
- I've never had grapes with two bites.
- Right.
- But it's like three or four bites.
- The firmness is so pleasing, too.
Just like the structural
integrity of the whole bunch.
It's like I'm lucid dreaming eating fruit.
- This was really cool.
It is very expensive.
If I gave this to my girlfriend,
she would probably cry from joy.
(laughter)
$50 plight right there.
- That was the juiciest one.
The ones at the bottom were the juiciest.
- [Steven] How is it?
(slow instrumental music)
- [Narrator] Oh yes.